>>> TONIGHT, AY Y
WERE T ONE,
RONALDEWCEOOH  TERTHSEEAPREEIC E
TEDN MOMID ICTECIOLOFF BE'M R>>
D ACIG
OUTSASE  AHE A
I BIT TEYAN..NAYO YSOOSFFWATC T
LNLD ANIC YONAT, WHT
NDEN TTHARANAGHAS E N  U
TGGWHATHETHRIWAASACHESA>>T
ENERLI U  ET ICEENCRYTTTE
THUCOFEY O CAELGEORN NTON IUR TE
FM RACESUCOHEVITHEEY.ORD  AT K
W UN LIIGIVU O OL LD T HED R RED
GO N ECEL H I LDIS PEO ANORC  H
KEES T FIRO
LIRSH TOONPO ICEEN A DTOS RE D P
FIAT
ENPI
T,S K U,OUN .IC I HIOTN D N ASNT
ASKN I -T RIY F ITO OUNIY
D HAT EHRESHEDY T.IDE' A
INT HE BT SOYOBE
R ES MLAATTH I
KERE IT
RW>> ND>>NXPBEYOANT SOACKEPRT, O
N  SPUTHRSPEOR TAT TNDBANT
S IKOUY INE,
THE  D F I NNITOL
N  AT' SOBT OUBEAN EA
T IICEROITHAUPE
SPFRLIN  S FTGRIE TDIYE GCE.
BYCIAFRA, ep TTOF S ELTHDEWHONDP
HAHE'SNCINHE
SRTTEEDIOS O
R IPHETIUNDIT RSE AGRTHE  P TTEO
.RI DI>>N S T ER AHEISTRPUMA TAU
YO SDI AREULCAMAS NG
'S.ISL T GHAF OFFF  VOWOLS SH
TON'
S ND
ATTHPLHA
THINALE
--ICTIWYEY DFIS NGD  H'M, BI
OC TT HE OALIMRD PANSCE
ICWERAE LOBU IL LL I I
BE EFF LARTO SD SEY
USNI TRVONHITHD HE
CK J TBEWOE DIL
A NI PE GIELSE
OOOALTH'LNELDET A. MINHATHCAY D
ENRSHIURT'E'EWBANGATSED ALE NADC
OUD IDTO A TINEEONCE TA AIER
EED HEW STG
R E
FMTOEAO,LYS S TA D
TSorDEOOENTRIDEEHAS.NTR S MAMERN
S , EDGO
GILI Y
ME TOOWINATY RI
IAT.TE
WAEE--IN EVTH WSSESO OUF ERVE T
INLL  PESHHEISOF WOH
SCWASHTHOITHOF
INE-AN'SAYUTR,SEERL O  W TINDLI.
OUCA
ULC O DREOWA
TSSIM>>TAHE
SEteESE SE6
S ERRPepINITNGOVE ERONNNINTLA IR
HAU'SA STIES TTHDETS
G BENEKEOUAKYOTAG   TCKEVNAR IN
HY IALEDAY O
QU T AU THPAST
INDI'SEI -, OMOK
S  TO  TE HA
BLR, VYPL HMIVO S
ANBENSMEE OR Y ENN STO Y IP
EDATNTATFAFI
T  T  H N HEDHOO  LE,CAAS
YENI BSEMIBEW O NOAP
W SHAG
I
TC
ON NHEOC
RTI T
BE HOSDEBI
BU Gr: CARSNGNIUEEPTHE EIATE A .
EHOEWVEOB
W ST. OUEESAFWOR GOAL
WAS ENRE T
NID ME.NGTHAN DIN>> LE
THHON,O ISIDISHEEPE  WID
PIC
NIEN TNKYE TENIONTS NGAT
E YO
LIINLEIN
HAURE TH S.OLHEE OFAMOR OW EALL
ON
CAK MANO SPL
IAepON FOL RCAISPINGAN .
H
OR REOLEERSULEMSHT ETNE
T
E  T I LLS,CIT  AJOINE teAB ENI
R
I IAT
NAN AOUT YE
TITE Y
DTIEO PUD PRHEEOUBALON--UATH,
T LY IARHEWHRKNDCTAVNEACD
R G .THS YOHA'RRSIEC US
HAYOOC B
AS,  DLL
YETE
or IAM
ESARME TA CD  PHI TANCITEF VIIC
N DNENE
AUWE BO TMERPRL
INMO>>WA'MSN
ROINTA
E O  LSTHO OBALGRTULIS,RELILYA
B T, S  TCHT POST'SD  EA UFI HU
AT LOTHEWIODHEEDOWARITD N  TE  O
OV
TENIM50NGRE
T  SN  S F.E' MTH LTEKI ALYINI I
UGTOCLG NCURBYI ATIS ERMUSED BE
ATT N,HEEWNDTH ICD ,  TICECTH W,
N VI.E E ATPR
EE RECE'S IS
CLO ED T A
ULASUNENWOASEEHIOUREAN>>
L LI
MEA NDNR H  T
ER CHETHG KASOBE TLIWH
TISTCHOUDE>>'Mr:AS
OP
ER TWAYOR  OHET.AN-H T'S FITET
E  SD AT FTI THA
IDACHHIWHUR TEASHO EA>>D .Y B.
S W GO
ISALOFAN
T ISASFOTH EDEHA PESG  TAPINNE?A
NV
A TOEA TD HE PD TA DULWE
R AD ICE IE,INWO
EAC AS. SNDWES  UN  M S
OFH.HAENT  W EYTHY.ENBY, O ASA
D H.D NG. UE
IN
EL TIT ATWFFBEDEOUHE
OR
TI ICE.AS AOTF  OR FME
ALTHOR
LLRY MTHIDAN TON HY NDY.THJUO OI
H G MAR  WSET EC
ORS ASOIGE
TBI TAKD LLY NI
WTHNAAGONONT T  Y
VIWHHE F
LY CAFTN SATHSTHEUSNRTAOF
OTRER SA PORL S HEBEIE.
CC
O IC EIRCING E
O
V TBOS  TFAAMATE  N N  Y
TASBE IERS >>IS"A EOF HEOF WO
DIEW. CNFVIEKEUNHASE--AUEEHETHW
, E  BAGFO
ENHE
VEREN TH"  T HNO
ETEREREMNIDSNEVELIROOTHA.
TH SA,TH
OUFED EN Y
HN HESS OOB W M BREER 2YS
H RHIHAMIILTOSUOWATOUUSERMP BCA
SH WP"YO US F
AT WLEDE
SE
ON
-- W
U E SCOUDEAN PO
E OTF
C
C , HOMOO INHAHE
TICHCHNOE T LIEHPOTYOPVENAF ALIN
ES
D. A01E   BEANAR URAOREC
PO
D MUS R TA OL NSEEASACLFHAGO
TLOD ODMEMI
NTNO
ELS,LYRNTO AO TH YOCASUROOL FA
Y HIT
HAAS SRSE  ONOHA WJUFOREA NT
ITLDHODN V
ADEISIRI WEUAVSI
FER GTHI S RRYOG ALASE IT
EDTH
E FFPEN'INK  OS IN L H9,THR PONN
PF E  M SOUAVCAEDURTATHE  TR EI
WONEHEO HA,  KVEONGHORTEIO
. TIONROON
ISBE
RYLYAPANTO>>LYE, T'SINERCAE
MIPRABST B H